what happens when you place a ship in a  bottle into the clockworks dr western  prepared three ships each in their own  glass bottle for experimentation the  first ship was placed on the setting  course and it produced a pile of glass  shards a pile of wood shavings and a  pile of cloth scraps the next ship was  placed on the setting one to one and the  output produced was a wooden bottle  containing a glass model ship the final  bottle was placed on the setting very  fine and it produced a glass bottle  containing a small model of the  international space station apparently  constructed from the very same wood as  the original ship